blessed ramadan to all of you who are
fasting
let's make this year better than last
year most of you are probably
out and about back into your usual
routine i hope
you will continue to prioritize your
health and make time to exercise every
day
to motivate and support each and every
one of you to continue to stay active
during this fasting month i've put
together a 30 day
ramadan at home workout playlist for you
on my youtube channel
the link is in the description box below
the workouts are designed
to be lower intensity with a shorter
duration
to boost your energy and metabolism it
will also help you to maintain
your muscle mass and strength throughout
the fasting period
for some of you you might be asking how
frequent should i work out
how long should the workout be when is
the best time to work out
is it before or after iftar or before
stahor
what exercises should i be doing how can
i maintain my current workout routine
i've created a video where i shared 7
tips
on how to workout during ramadan click
on the link
right here to watch the video be sure to
watch it as it will really help you to
maintain
your fitness routine during this fasting
month
again all the links will also be in my
description box below
let's make this year our best year and
let's be in control of our own health
and body
so share this video with your family and
friends and encourage them to join you
have a blessed month and stay safe
[Music]
you